hey guys I'm just Mozilla and it's
Friday which means I've got five has
this week's best stories in gaming to
get you all filled in on what's been
going on let's do it evolves urgent beta
is now live on Xbox one so if you have
that console you can get stuck into all
the asymmetrical competitive multiplayer
goodness the beta is available to
anybody with a gold subscription and 20
gigabytes to spare on their xbox one and
it'll run until january nineteen servers
will be switched off on monday at eight
pm TBT as for the content you'll be
facing off against or adopting the role
of two monsters the Goliath and Kraken
there are also eight hunters playable on
12 different maps on January 17 you'll
also be able to give evacuation mode a
shot it's worth mentioning that any
progress made during the beta will carry
through to your full game which releases
on every 10 game is on PC and ps4 can
also get their hands on the game but
there are conditions you'll have to meet
which you can find on gamespot
rocks are have delayed GTA 5 on pc again
to polish and tweak the title before its
release you can now expect the game on
March 24 which is a significant change
from the fall 2014 original release date
Rockstar explained that the second
delays in the best interest of the game
and depends if you're wondering how your
PC will fare in running the
action-packed game you can check out
both the minimum and recommended specs
on site
in super random news things that combine
not the creator of Minecraft with pop
star Selena Gomez the now super-rich
game dev had a housewarming party after
selling his company mojang to Microsoft
for 2.5 billion he outfitted jay-z and
Beyonce for a 70 million dollar mansion
in Beverly Hills then he threw a huge
party and invited the likes of Selena
Gomez said and respawn co-founder Vince
Zampella among other gay me people like
Anita sarkeesian as you do the moral of
this story is obviously make games be
rich and buy a sweet mansion with a
candy room moving on in total more
things the next entry in the series has
been leaked to fire it up look let's not
suppose to be out for a week creative
Assembly's creative director Mike
Simpson worked in the book that they're
planning to take on the fantasy
franchise Warhammer in their next game
total war warhammer the game hasn't been
confirmed officially by Sega or Creative
Assembly just yet
and then user why we can't have nice
things the infamous and controversial
allegedly not Daisy cloned the war z has
sold almost three million copies the
news was announced by the game's
executive producer Sergey Titov he said
all sorts of things in a post-mortem on
Gamasutra including that the name choice
was poor and the communication with fans
wasn't optimal but they're glad to have
such a success despite the game being so
bad it needed to be rebranded into
infestation survivor stories after it's
removal from steam for having a
misleading description let me know down
in the comments if you've ever bought a
game knowing it was bad and why I
certainly did about a month ago when I
bought air control to play on my show
the gist and I have not gotten up I
definitely regret it as for what's
inside this week check out my just
episode on how the ps4 can sell loads
this year in two minutes tackle DLC and
we unbox the new 3ds XL that is it for
me this week thanks for sticking around
have yourselves a great weekend and I'll
capture get on Monday
you